I heard there was a story during the rounds in the
Brady household - this one. It's Mole's Star which I
know you've been reading to your new baby son. I
decided to have a look at this Brady and to see
if it's sort of- if it was appropriate shall
we say. So um yeah I thought- should we have a look?
So it's basically about a mole who looks up at
the stars and decides to sort of basically take
them all and put him in his burrow which- I'm not
really sure about this. So so let's just let's just
start reading it shall we? So I'll read it like
Jackanory right? So Mole's Star by Britta Teckentrup.
"Mole lived deep under the ground. He loved
his cosy home of burrows, dens and tunnels. But
sometimes he felt a little lonely in the dark.
Every night Mole popped his head out of his
molehill to say hello to the stars. He sat on his
favorite rock gazing at the beautiful twinkling
lights in the sky. One night, as Mole sat on his
rock, he saw a dazzling shooting star and quickly
closed his eyes to make a wish."
We've all done thatright? Actually I haven't because I've never seen
a shooting star but that's another story.
" 'I wish Icould own all the stars in the world' he whispered."
So let's think about this. So what can Mole
actually see? So these stars that he's claiming
to want, what can he actually see? Well I think
moles are pretty blind so I'm not sure if you
can see any stars. So maybe he's talking about
all the stars - by last estimate the number of stars
in the observable universe is about 200 billion
trillion stars. Roughly about 100 billion in each
galaxy, 100 billion to 400 billion in each galaxy
and there's about 2 trillion galaxies okay. So
that's a lot right? That's a lot. I think that's
too many, I think that's greedy. What I think we
should focus on is that Mole's actually after
roughly the number of stars that a typical
human or any creature on Earth can see. There's
about 5,000 of those. So typically a human if say
you can see up to what we call the brightness of
the star that goes up to about magnitude six, and
that's about roughly about as far as humans can
see. Maybe a little bit further but but that's
that's roughly about this sort of dimmest star that
we can see. And there's about 5,000 of those that are
visible on Earth, okay. So that's probably- I've got
a little database of them here actually; it's a
database of the brightest stars in in the sky. You
know things like the Yale bright star catalogue but
there's a few others in there as well and this
includes all the stars that we can definitely see.
Usual suspects in there like Sirius for example;
what else is there, we've got Vega which is you
know very bright star. Rigel here I think that's
that's one of the the nearby ones right in Alpha
Centauri. So you know so these-
- (Brady: I see Betelgeusethere)
- Betelgeuse there yeah yeah that's
right yeah yeah. So we've got the usual suspects,
there are a whole bunch of others as well. I filtered
this to just only consider those whose magnitude
is six or less, and so that's the brightest ones
that humans can definitely see. As I said if you've
got a particularly good eye you might see a few
more but let's not worry about them because we
know Mole doesn't have a good eye okay. Mole wants
all the stars okay. So "When Mole opened his eyes
he couldn't believe what he saw. There were ladders
all around him leading up to the sky."
So theseladders what are these? So these ladders- if you look
at the picture Brady, these ladders are going up to
all the stars. So I'm trying to figure okay so we've
got all these ladders and they're going up to all
the stars that the Mole- that we're saying these
5,000 stars that we're gonna- at least humans can see
okay right. So I looked at my database and I sort
of said, well okay how...you know how how how far
are these stars away? How much ladder do I need?
Okay so this database includes the distances to
to all those stars that we're talking about, all
those 5,000 or so stars. And the total
distance in light years that you would need
of ladders to reach these stars is about 786
million light years. It's quite a lot of ladder
right. I decided to think, okay can actually can we
make these ladders? These ladders which are going
up to all the stars, right, can we make them all?
So I thought okay, what should we make out of? Well
we're gonna need something light I think, so I said
let's go for balsa wood. Okay so balsa wood has a
density of about 0.1 gram per centimeter cubed.
I checked and you can get balsa wood down to about a
diameter of about 0.2 centimeters. You know your
your sort of rods of balsa. If you put all that
together and you try to build your ladders yeah
with rungs you know sort of every so often. Then
typically I think you're going to need about
ten thousand billion billion kilograms worth
of ladder. Actually the exact number is about 9.9
times 10 to the 21 kilograms. Now that sounds like
a lot right? It sounds like a lot of balsa wood
right that you need to make these ladders. And
you're thinking, no way Mole's going to do this.
But actually this is about that this is this
is a lot less than the mass of the Earth. It's
about a thousand times less than the mass of the
Earth. The mass of the Earth is about six times
ten to the 24 kilograms; so so roughly about six
million billion billion kilograms. So it's about a
thousand times more than than this this the weight
of these ladders.
- (So ladders going to the 5,000
or so stars we can see - if they're quite flimsy)
(and made of balsa wood weigh much less thanthe Earth?)
- Yep I couldn't believe it I was really
surprised by it, really surprised by it. So Ithought okay-
- (Did you double check that?)
- I've double
checked- there's my code Brady, double checked,
triple checked - then where's the ladders. Total ladder
heights, here we go. Yeah I mean it's just - the mass
of the Earth is big, this is what it is, the mass
of the Earth is really big I think that that's the
bottom line. It's the mass of the Earth that's big.
(But the Earth is small on the cosmic scale! It's a speck of dust
we forever hear)
- These ladders are quite flimsy,
not very compact, you know they're just flimsy
ladders that go and then we've got this this
huge whole earth that's roughly spherical which
is a really efficient way to store stuff in terms
of volume. I was really surprised, I was really
surprised I agree. I actually told Renata about
this, my wife right, I said- she she was like 'really?'
She goes, is there enough carbon? That's a good
question. So I found- there's something called the
Deep Carbon Observatory which basically- you know
they're worried about how much carbon there is. And
they've done an estimate for how much carbon there
is on Earth. Well it's not quite enough; it's not
it's not that far short but it's not quite enough.
It's about 1.85 times 10 to the 21 kilograms, so
that's 1,850 billion billion kilograms of carbon on
Earth and in the earth. So there's not quite enough.
- (Is that assuming balsa wood is just made of carbon?)
Yes it is. So I mean most most of balsa- most of balsa wood is actually empty space, essentially
just just air. But actually the heavy stuff and what's
giving balsa wood its weight is probably mostly
carbon. So yeah I mean there's just not there's
not enough carbon on Earth. But it's not that
far short, it's about  you know roughly- what's
that? Factor of maybe maybe five just under five
different? It's just not quite enough which is annoying.
So Mole, you can't make this out of balsa wood unless
you're going to start going off to other planets
to collect your balsa wood; you're not- you've
not got enough on Earth. So okay let's make it out of
carbon fiber. So we're going to make these ladders
out of carbon fiber. Now carbon fiber is actually
more dense than balsa wood but of course it can
be a lot thinner, okay. So it's about two grams per
centimeter cubed is its density; but you can get
the diameter of a strand you know of carbon fibers
down to about a thousandth of a centimeter. So you
can get it you can get a lot thinner. Okay now
we're not going to worry about where Mole
could actually climb this at this stage, but we
can get much thinner ladders, okay and we can
try and rebuild. So how how much is ladders made
out of really thin carbon fiber is going to weigh?
Well I reckon it's going to be about 3.5 times
10 to the 18 kilograms - 3.5 million trillion
kilograms. Now that's way less than the mass of
the Earth and actually it's less than the mass
of carbon on Earth, so there's enough carbon
on Earth to make these these carbon fibers.
But there's a catch. Okay so we could in principle
on Earth make these carbon fiber ladders going to
all the stars right that we can see; but the
problem is there's not enough surface carbon.
Okay? So the amount of surface carbon according to
this this again this this deep carbon observatory
is about 4.35 times 10 to the 16 kilograms,
so that's 43,000 trillion kilograms. That's
the amount of surface carbon; so the carbon
in the air, the carbon in the land, the carbon
in the oceans. Okay so there's not enough of
that to make your carbon fiber ladders.
To make your carbon fiber ladders you're going
to have to get deep into the Earth, right? Into
the Earth's core and start getting the carbon out
of that. And okay that's gonna be tricky but in
principle if Mole can do it he can make us carbon
fiber ladders going to all the stars. Okay okay, carry on.
(Job done. What does Mole do next?)
- "Mole didn'tthink twice. He scurried up and down the
ladders, collecting the stars one by one and
carrying them home." Okay Mole now we need to
think about this, right. So Mole is now running
up and down these ladders - of which we need to
remind ourselves, they are in total 786 million
light years high. How long is this is this going
to take him? I feel like it's gonna be quite a
long time Brady. All right? So I looked it up, so
how fast do moles travel? They travel at about six
kilometers per hour. So given he's got to go up and
down the ladders right - and let's suppose he's
doing it at six kilometers an hour, which maybe
that's a bit of a you know a being a bit generous
because frankly he's going up right. So- but okay
we'll we'll do we'll use that number. It's going
to take him Brady, 280,000 trillion years. So that's
2.8 times 10 to the 17 years. That's a long time,
that's a very long time, that's much longer than
the age of the universe. It's certainly longer
than the lifetime of a star, right. So a star-
a star lives for about 10 billion years. This
is way longer than that. So I don't think this
is practical for Mole to be doing this this
way, right, he's going to get to these stars
and they'll all be dead. So what's the point right?
So I think Mole has to find another way to travel.
So I looked at it, so I said okay maybe you
could travel on like let's say the Apollo 10
spacecraft - very fast, one of the fastest space craft ever made.
Thatgoes about just under 40,000 kilometers per hour.
If Mole did it using the Apollo 10 spacecraft
it would take him about 43 trillion years. That's
still not enough - stars are all still going to
be dead. So then I went okay what's the fastest
spacecraft we've ever made? Not necessarily
crewed or mole-d - that's the Juno spacecraft, okay.
That can go at 365,000 kilometers per hour which
I frankly think is amazing. But that's still gonna
take you - or take Mole - 4.6 trillion years to
do this journey. It's just way too long; all the
stars are going to be dead. Well not all of them,
we might get to the first couple but that's- you
know it's just it's it's it's no good. Okay he
needs to do something beyond the technology
we have available right so he's gonna have
to start going close to the speed of light.
This is just- no choice in the matter. I crunched the
numbers on this a little bit to say about how fast
is it going to have to go to get to these stars
in his lifetime? So moles can live between roughly
three three to six years; six years if they're
lucky but they normally crock it around three okay.
So here's what I figured out: so if
Mole travels within one billionth
of a billionth of the speed of light - so really
really close to the speed of light - within one
billionth of a billionth of the speed of light he
will be able to go up and collect all the stars in
around two years four months.
- (Traveling at like0.999999 speed of light?)
- Yeah. Within one billionth of
a billionth of the speed of light; just shy of it
that fraction. So you might say well how does
how does that make any sense? This is- you've got
to do 786 um million light years. Okay so this this
is where relativity comes in and starts helping
us- and helps or helps Mole actually. So we're
waiting for Mole, he's going to collect these stars.
Now for him to collect all those stars - 786 million
light years there, 786 million light years back - in
total it's going to take him about 1.6 billion
years as far as we're concerned. We're going to
be waiting about 1.6 billion years here on Earth
for him to go and get these stars. But Mole is
traveling super fast, so time ticks differently
for him because of relativity. We've talked about this
with Usain Bolt before if you remember Brady, right?
Well Mole is going a lot faster than Usain Bolt,
he's going very very just just shy of the speed of
light. Because of the way of time time changes
at speed for Mole he would actually complete
this journey in like I said two years four months.
Which is which is just within his lifetime which
is pretty cool. And actually so going at that
speed by the way I sort of calculated how long
Mole would consider himself as taking to go to
Alpha Centauri, our nearest star system. And that
would be about 0.3 seconds - he would do it about
0.3 seconds. So yeah going pretty fast but doable.
I thought it was quite interesting. Okay,carry on.
- (Carry on, what does Mole do?)
Okay so he's brought these home so: "That
night, his borrow was full of shimmering starlight."
So you see what Mole has done now- so let me
all the carry on reading. "Mole loved his
bright new home so much, he wanted to stay there
forever." Now Mole is probably going to get what he
wishes for here quite frankly; because now what
Mole appears to have done here is get the stars
and shove him into his burrow. Okay, that's a
lot of mass in a very small space. Right so
typical burrow of a mole; right well okay it's
about five centimeters sort of wide about four
centimeters high and it can be up to about 70
metres long actually. It's still not a very big
volume. It's it's still you know only about 0.14
of a cubic metre, it's not it's not a big volume.
But how much- how what's the mass of the stars that
he's trying to shove into this this burrow? Okay
well I go back to my little database. I had to
um I had to actually calculate the the mass
these of these stars based on on the luminosity
and all that sort of stuff. So I got an est- there's
a bit of an estimate to be fair, but I think
it's pretty accurate, it won't be miles off.
And I reckon these stars, these 5,000 stars or so
that we've got, their total mass is about 20,175
times the mass of the Sun. It sounds reasonable
actually, it's not- it doesn't sound like a crazy
number given that you know you've got about 5,000
of them. So it's about 20,000
times the mass of the Sun. So this is how much
mass Mole is trying to get into his burrow. Well
okay suppose you try to cram that much
mass into as small a space as possible;
how small is it going to be before it collapses
into a black hole? You calculate something called
the Schwarzschild radius which is the size
of the event horizon of a mass that big.
And for this much mass the Schwarzschild radius is
about 59,000 kilometers. So that means you cannot
cram this amount of mass into a space less than 59
less than- roughly 59,000 kilometers in in radius.
You just can't. Otherwise it's going to turn into a
black hole. So not only can Mole not get this into
into his burrow - or if he does he's going to start
turning his burrow into a black hole - he's actually
going to turn the Earth into a black hole right?
Because the Earth is only about 6,000 kilometers
in radius right, so trying to cram all this stuff into
into you know a small region in and around the Earth
eventually you're going to start creating a black
hole that's going to swallow the whole Earth. So that's
pretty pretty reckless behaviour by Mole Iwould say.
- (So you couldn't even fit all these)
(stars into the Earth?)
- No. The best you can do is
create a black hole which is about- which is about
sort of 10 times the size of the Earth. That's
the best you could do, that's Mole's best tactic.
So yeah so that's- so what's gonna happen
next Mole? So he wanted to stay there forever.
Right well let's think about this.
- In his blackhole)
- He's now a black hole so maybe he is going to
stay there forever. But actually not necessarily,
okay. He's in this black hole now, is he going to
stay there forever? No because remember black
holes radiate. They give off a type of- when you
apply quantum mechanics to the edge of a black hole
you realise that they're not as black as they seem,
they give off this radiation which is named after
Stephen Hawking, so they give off Hawking radiation.
So there is a time it takes for this black hole to
evaporate okay? It's quite a long time though, right.
So this black hole, it's going to take about 10 to
the 80 years to evaporate.
- (10 to the 80? That's a)
(familiar number.)
- It's a number of particles in the
universe, that's why you're over it. But that's a
total coincidence, it's just it's just this the
complete coincidence. But yeah so it's about 10
to the 80 years for this black hole to evaporate.
So Mole could get out of this black hole that he's
created rather recklessly in 10 to the 80 years;
however he's not going to get out as a mole, he's
likely going to come out as just Hawking radiation
which is not great.
"But as the days went by, he started
to miss his favorite rock. So one evening, he
popped his head out of his molehill, and saw...
nothing. The sky was dark." Well it's not really
a surprise is it because you've created a black hole.
And also he's not getting out actually. So
I I also wondered like what- so we say he could get
out of the black hole after 10 to the 80 years
as Hawking radiation; what's the universe going
to look like then? That stage of the universe, very
far future we're talking about, and the universe is
going to be black hole dominated then. There's
going to be an era between 10 to the 40 and
basically googol years when the universe is just
dominated by black holes. All the stuff has fallen
into black holes; some of the black holes will
be radiate- will have radiated away, the smaller
ones will have done, larger ones will still be
radiating. But the universe is going to be black
hole dominated. So actually the sky is going
to be pretty black right, because there's going
to be no stars shining, they've all been swallowed
by black holes. Yeah well we we carry on. "Deer
stood in the clearing with tears in her eyes.
Where are all the stars, she said? Field mouse
- field mouse is not happy by the way - field mouse
shook his head sadly. My children love to stargaze
while I sing their bedtime lullaby. They will be
so sad" I hope Mole's feeling guilty. "The stars help
me find my way, said fox. Where can they be, sighed
bear, I have flown far and high, said owl, the stars
are gone." So I presume that owl is saying that
that she's flown 786 million light years which
seems a bit of an exaggeration but we'll move on
from that. "Mole felt terrible. He didn't know the
other animals loved the stars as much as he did. He
scurried into the trees hiding himself away. Mole
walked deeper and deeper into the forest. What
had he done? Then Mole saw something glinting
through the trees. A star lay in a puddle,
its light faded and dull. Could it be his
special shooting star? Mole bent close. Oh how I
wish I had never taken the stars, he whispered."
I didn't whisper that did I? "The stars began to
twinkle and ladders appeared." Oh so ladders are
back. So he must have had to go somewhere else for
the rest of the ladders now, because he's used up
all the carbon on Earth for his original set of ladders.
"Mole didn't think twice. He rushed back to the
clearing, the star lighting his way. I'm sorry he
cried, I took the stars, I wanted them for myself.
But now I know the stars belong to everyone
I'm going to put them back." Okay so I think
this is where we have to start thinking about this
again now right? So we've already established he's
created a black hole, and that black hole is going
to get take 10 to the 80 years to evaporate okay.
So Mole ain't getting out for a long time. And when
he does get out the universe is now going to be
black hole dominated with barely any stars in it
at all, all the stars are swallowed by black holes.
Okay now those black holes will evaporate
themselves after about a googol years; so
there's nothing really to see, the universe is just
a dull and boring place of Hawking radiation. Just
cold and miserable - and it's the heat death of the
universe essentially. If Mole really wants to bring
the stars back, and wants to be able to look up at
the sky again and see the stars, I think he's going
to have to wait for a Poincaré recurrence. I
think that's the only option. Whenever you have
a finite system you always get back to where you
started from. So so for example I take a pack of
cards, so there's a finite number of arrangements
for a pack of cards. If I shuffle the cards enough
I'll eventually get back to the original order of
the cards. It'll take many many many shuffles but I
will get there. And it's the same, you think about
gases in a room - so you put all the gases in the
corner of a room and they move around and there's
this random movement of the of the gas particles.
Eventually after a very very long time they will
at some point end up back in the far corner of the
room. That will happen. Okay so you always get this
this recurrence in a finite system; and we do
believe our universe is a finite system. It's to
do- we we know this because we can look at the
entropy of our universe, we understand that it's
finite and we think it's finite and so therefore
it's a finite system. And so it has a Poincaré
recurrence where it will get back to any initial
point. Okay? So if Mole wants to get back to his
starting point, which is the stars there; this is
the only way I think he can do it, he's gonna have
to wait wait for it - I think this is exceeding a
mole lifetime by the way: 10 to the 10 to the
122 years. So 10 to the 10 to the 122 years so
an astonishingly long time. That's the order of
magnitude that Mole's gonna have to wait before
he gets his stars back and you know he makes up
for his his error. Yeah long time.
- (Mole's star)
- Mole's star!
(A bit flawed)
- A bit flawed yeah; but not entirely.
The ladders were fine, right, the ladders were fine.
Here's a fiendish puzzle from the clever people at Jane
Street, custom made for today's video. You have to
place 2 and only 2 stars in each row, column,
and section of this grid. No two stars can directly
neighbour each other either, even diagonally. If
you can crack it the stars will then mark out the
letters to solve this riddle. What would happen if
Mole didn't put all the stars back in the galaxy?
I'll put a link to the puzzle below this
video so you can click straight through to it.
And while you're on the Jane Street website
why not check out the amazing opportunities
they have to work with them in offices all
around the world. Our thanks to Jane Street
(Let me ask you one more question: if people really
enjoy big big numbers and they enjoy books, what)
(book should they buy?)
- Oh well they should buy
'fantastic numbers and where to find them'!
Which can say, which is my book.
- (You've writtena book about big numbers?! You kept that secret!)
Yeah I don't tell anybody about it, yeah. It's got
all the numbers- all your favorite numbers in
Brady. It's got like a googol, a googolplex, it's
got Graham's number and tree(3). It's all our
favourites - it's got some small numbers as well.
- (Iknow it was released in the UK, it's a real pity)
(it hasn't been released in America.)
- No it has beenreleased in America Brady.
- (What it's out in America too?!)
It's out in America, it's out everywhere.
- (Oh well!)
- You can go- it doesn't look
like this in America, looks a bit different, but
um it's still there and it's the same
name - fantastic numbers. Yeah you can get
it in a get it online or you can get it
in you know Barnes and Noble for example
those sorts of places.
- (I wonder if therewill be a link in the video description?)